this is a very big package of gratitude
being delivered to you guys I'm always
saying thank you for something but truly
I'm very grateful today so thank you on
this beautiful Sunday here to ye were
working here I'll show you guys you're
like damn Rock don't see this beautiful
beautiful beautiful Hawaii a place where
I was raised a lot of defining moments
here on this island for me anyway
speaking of defining moments we had a
defining moment at the box office this
weekend where we launched a movie that I
helped produce called Shazam
and you guys have made it a really big
success around the world the box office
success is very healthy and robust and
once they thank you guys so so much for
making this number one and I wanna it's
great that the critics love the movie
it's awesome we're at 92 or 93 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes which again is always
awesome that everybody's loving the
movies but the best part about Shazam is
the audience's reactions and scores you
the audience the people have given us
aids across the board around the world I
always say I've got one boss and that's
you the people the audience and my main
objective myself and several bucks
Productions is always to think audience
first and make sure that you guys are
thoroughly entertained and you are you
were and again couldn't be more grateful
and very very happy about that
very gratifying you know this project
Shazam we had some challenges and we
took a risk and that risk is as we were
developing this a few years ago the the
challenges and the struggles that we
were having and that was gnawing at my
gut is that we were trying to tell two
origin stories in one script so for
those who know the comic books and the
mythology of the comics of Shazam knows
that Shazam is connected to Black Adam
Black Adam is an antihero
or villain who I cannot wait to play
I've been developing this and it's been
with me in my DNA for over ten years now
we should start shooting that in about a
year I'm very excited about that but
anyway the challenges were as you guys
can imagine you're trying to tell two
very big origin stories in the world of
comic books of this DC Universe two very
important characters trying to tell
they're both both their origin stories
in one script I didn't think it was
working
finally I called up Warner Brothers Toby
Emmerich my good buddy who runs one of
others nicer brother we have to split
these stories and make two different
movies he said you know what it is a
great idea and let's do it so we rolled
the dice and because you never know what
these things you know and I did feel in
my gut that that out of respect to both
origin stories and those who know the
mythology and the backstories of Shazam
and Black Adam know that they are vastly
different backstories so again we roll
the dice hues are and it's a big success
and I couldn't be happier for our stars
Zach we combine and Shazam filmmakers
and one of others and most importantly
you guys out there watching so thank you
guys if you haven't you seems your song
go out check it out you're gonna love it
it is a big fun very well crafted very
well done
family movie that at its core as has
this this right here not my sternum or
my pecs but in it as it has great heart
and heart these are an anchor and can't
wait for guys it I can't wait to play
Black Adam
because they're all getting their ass
kicked when I played my black Adam that
day of reckoning is coming for everyone
anyway guys thank you again and Zack our
star congratulations buddy you did it
very happy very proud and everybody
around the world thank you again and
enjoy is that everybody it's Charlie do
you smell the Black Adam movie that the
rock is cooking he just totally threw
the gauntlet down they are all getting
their asses kicked when I play Black
Adam so I'll explain what's going on
with the black out a movie what he's
saying here about when production is
gonna start and with that movie's gonna
be like vs the Shazam sequels because
they also just greenlit the Shazam
sequel it's gonna be written by the
person that wrote the first Shazam movie
like you did a good job in the first one
everybody liked that story just come
back and do the next one we're still
doing that big IMAX ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment about
black adam or Shazam on the video so as
the rock is saying he was a producer on
the Shazam movie if you guys didn't
notice through his seven bucks
production company which was surprising
because it sounds like based on what he
was saying is they originally wanted to
do a version of their origin story where
you do black Adam and Shazam in the same
movie which would have been a more
faithful adaptation of the Jeff Jones
new 52 Shazam origin story they rebooted
Shazam during the new 52 but while they
were telling his story they also gave
you little snippets of black Adams
backstory which is a couple of similar
moments that you see during the Shazam
movie so I'll say careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the Shazam movie
because we'll be talking about very
specific stuff in a very specific black
at a moment in the Shazam movie there's
a moment where you get the Shazam Lee
the Shazam family all getting their
powers he says grab the staff and say
the thing that I say to activate my
powers so they all say the word Shazam
he opens up his heart to them and gives
them a portion of his power becoming the
Shazam family from the comics the idea
of the family that you make for yourself
versus the families that you're born
with is very core to the film but during
the new 52 comic book version of his
origin story Black Adam is an adult
already it's actually one of his nephews
is his relative that goes to the rock of
eternity and asked for the power to help
his family the wizard Shazam in the
magical council grant him that power so
the little boy comes back
his uncle black Adam and says we have
the power now I'll share it with you we
could be a family it's just like the
Shazam family with Billy I'll share this
power with you except it gets really
really dark black Adam accepts the power
then takes the rest of it from this
little kid it's not like he's killing
his son but he kills a very close family
member so it just starts Black Adam on
the very familiar path to wanting to
take all the power for himself give me
your power which is a little bit up
during the Shazam movie through the dr.
sivana character though he gets most of
his power from the seven deadly sins he
still tries to take the power of the
wizard Shazam from Billy give me your
power
so as the rock says when they were
trying to develop that version of the
Shazam movie they're like this is just
way too different these origin stories
one is way too dark this one is way too
light we have to separate this into two
different movies apparently he had to
run that by the people at DC which lets
you know that originally it wasn't DC's
idea to do things this way which i think
is interesting but that sort of explains
why you heard about the rock being cast
as Black Adam years ago it's been 84
years since the rock was cast as Black
Adam but we still haven't seen the Black
Adam movie but that's why because they
wanted to break the movies up do the
Shazam movie first wait to see how that
did financially then proceed forward
so as the rock says they're probably
gonna start shooting the Black Adam
movie next year for a release the year
after so we'll probably be sitting our
asses down in the theater to watch the
Black Adam movies sometime during 2021
he makes like 4 billion films a year but
based on his current filming schedule he
is on track to start shooting that next
year but here's the thing how are they
gonna change his story based on what we
saw during the Shazam movie because
there was a Black Adam seen during the
Shazam movie is just a lot of people may
have missed it if they weren't paying
attention but it's when the wizard is
giving Billy that magical PowerPoint
presentation like he gives you
flashbacks to guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 we're here the living planet was
giving his PowerPoint presentation to
the guardians of the galaxy this is what
I do this is how everything works the
wizard Shazam tells Billy about a person
quote-unquote who is black Adam that
they mistakenly gave their power to who
in the movies version of events had so
much darkness in his heart and hatred
for mankind that he released the seven
deadly sins on them as an act of revenge
and it wiped out whole civilization so
we're talking
5,000 years ago in the comics later
Black Adam killed the rest of the
magical council except for the wizard
but in the movies version of events
it was the seven deadly sins that killed
the other members of the magical council
so just expect minor changes to the
Black Adam origin story during the Black
Adam movie but here's the thing what
they might do is they might also rope in
some of the black Adams story from the
recent rebirth comics because what did
they tease in the Shazam post-credit
scene is that they're going into the
magic lands the seven different realms
of magic from the rebirth comics even
though the Shazam family hasn't
accidentally quote-unquote found that
yet the mr. mind dr. sivana post-credits
scene is all about them getting ready to
try and take over or co-opt the magic
lands so during the comic book version
of that story Black Adam shows up after
the Shazam family goes into the magic
lands to try and learn what's going on
but because they're all little kids they
have no idea why the magic lands exist
and why they were separated from each
other in why there's this barrier
preventing them from coming back into
our realm so Black Adam shows up in that
story and says Billy you're an idiot
what have you done there was a reason
why the magical council separated all
the magical lands from each other so
he's sort of entering the story under
the guise that he's trying to help
prevent all chaos from breaking loose
because his alignment is lawful evil he
has a very strong sense of order it's
just that his idea of order is very very
counter to what all the heroes want but
because that story is still unfolding as
we speak like they're still writing that
story we don't know exactly how it's
gonna pan out so we don't know exactly
what black Adam is gonna do to try and
co-opt the situation in backstab the
Shazam family usually that's what
happens is he'll team up with heroes but
then wind up betraying them in order to
take something for himself so based on
what the rock says that he's cooking in
this video he's gonna be doing the black
out of origin story straight up whether
or not it said in present-day we don't
know then once they develop that
character and everybody understands who
he is what his character is like what
the relationships are like then they put
him in a Shazam movie where they face
off against each other
but let me know in the comments what do
you want them to do with Black Adam
after the Black Adam movie and after
they put him in Shazam do you just want
to see him pop up as a villain all over
the DC Universe because the rock sounds
like he would be down to kick all the
rest of the Justice League characters
asses
regardless of who's playing those
characters by the time they get to that
there's a whole bunch of Game of Thrones
stuff happening this week and Avengers
endgame because they're in the middle of
their press tour so there might be more
footage for everything coming really
soon leave all your requests in the
comments below
while you wait for all that click here
to watch the Shazam post-credit scene
and click here for that brand new
Avengers endgame trailer from the
beginning of the movie thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight